the Joe Rogan experience I feel like
there's with many people this stress of
this question is also accentuated by
unhappy lives son sacks and accentuated
by unhappy choices by being trapped
there's a big difference between not
knowing what the meaning of life is and
god I got to get the [ __ ] out of this
job I have to I can't live my life this
way what's the meaning of life if this
is my life which is why I always start
with let's get you rich first mmm that's
why I'm very practical about it because
look the you know Buddha was a prince
okay he started out really rich and then
he got to go off in the woods and in the
old days what happened was if you wanted
to be peaceful inside you would become a
monk you would renounce everything you'd
become an ascetic you would give
everything up you renounce women men
you'd renounce children you'd renounce
money you'd renounce politics science
technology everything and you would go
out in the woods by yourself you to give
everything up to be free inside well
today we have this wonderful invention
called money-making the store stuff up
in a bank account okay and you can
basically save up you can you can work
really hard you can do great things for
society and society will give you money
for giving it things that it wants and
it doesn't know how to get and then you
can save that up and you can live well
below with your means and you can find a
certain freedom in that and that will
give you the time and the energy to
pursue your own internal peace and
happiness so I believe the solution to
making everybody happy is to give them
what they want let's get them all rich
well let's get them all fit and healthy
and then let's get them all happy is are
those things even possible
absolutely everyone can be written
everyone can be read everyone here's my
thought exercise for now it seems like
we're in an infomercial my home this is
my rolls-royce yeah so that's a good
point so everything that I've ever
created on this topic of how to make
money I would never charge a dollar for
mmm because that would ruin it that
would show that I'm just another
huckster who's gonna get rich off of you
there are no get-rich-quick somebody
else trying to get rich off of you right
so it's so to me it's more of a
philosophical contribution we're for it
to have meeting and to be legit I can't
charge you anything for it
but yes everybody can be rich and let me
give you a thought exercise
okay imagine if tomorrow we could wave a
wand and everybody was trained as a
scientist or an engineer everybody even
if you weren't very good
you had enough understanding computers
you could write some code you could
build some hardware and don't tell me
people can't do it because they can
that's just a tyranny of soft
expectations that's just you looking
down on somebody else they can't do it
they just have to be educated now if
they're educated all this hardware
software engineers scientists biologists
technicians hard sciences not the social
sciences we would all be done within
five years robots would be doing
everything from cleaning toilets to
cooking food to flying airplanes and
driving goobers and what would we be
doing we would be doing all creative
jobs to entertain each other and
researching science and technology we
would have wonderful lives so it is
really just a question of Education
nothing else is this a scale issue
though I mean you're talking about it as
if this would work with 300 million
people it'll work with 10 billion people
it'll work is base fairing race with a
hundred trillion people just we have the
resources we have the ability the
universe is infinite resources you build
it you know have you heard of a Dyson
Sphere mm-hmm you know you pull the
Dyson Sphere on a star and you gather
all its energy like that there's so much
energy out there one asteroid it's got
all the minerals that we need
one Sun one solar system has got all the
power we will need for a long long time
you know we can extract it of nuclear
fusion you know we're not that far from
those kinds of technologies working it's
just a question of guts and you know an
interest like we should be building
nuclear fusion test plants on the moon
the moon should be littered with no
downside right yeah if you could how
would that work well it is send a bunch
of people up there to work well the
problem robots
the problem with fission nuclear fission
is that you know nature creates energy
through nuclear energy right like the
Sun creates energy nuclear energy now
for transmission we use photons because
photons don't interact and so photons
are great for information transmission
but they're actually not great for
energy transmission for energy creation
you want nuclear to work and the problem
is because nuclear energy you know we
built it with a bomb we have dirty nukes
all those kinds of problems with fukushi
Three Mile Island Chernobyl we don't
innovate anymore on nukes imagine if
when the first steam engine blew up we
said oh no more steam engines for a
while or very carefully regulated
billion dollars of regulation
you can't innovate that way when the
first airplane crashed we said no more
innovation in airplanes right so we need
a way to iterate on nuclear fission and
eventually fusion and get them working
safely cleanly passive it's a failure
etc if we're gonna find our way out of
the energy trap and the best place to do
that is someplace like in the Moon or
Mars do you think that it's actually a
possibility that they could get nuclear
power to the point where it's not a
detriment because what everyone's
worried about is a meltdown right yeah
and we do have these old plants that are
running that are running on this this is
50 year old technology it's crazy
because there's no ability to shut them
off right very old technology they do
now have Gen 4 nuclear reactors that are
passive failsafe so in other words when
they fail they fail into us we pull the
plug on them they fail into a state
where there's no leakage there's no
problem where their default is a
positive outcome as opposed to the
current ones the old ones where if you
unplug them like and these even these
Gen 4 or just gen 4 they're not Gen 5
and I just 1800 where we're
microprocessors right and that should be
something that people are working
towards I hope so I mean an ideal world
we would the problem is if you have
nuclear energy on the moon how do you
get it home right so what you actually
got to do is you've got a rabbit on the
moon and you're using it there maybe to
launch more satellites more rockets
further out into the solar system and
that's the initial use case but then
eventually the technology gets so good
you can bring it home